Então, na aula de hoje eu
quero explorar um tópico
que não está relacionado com o
que estávamos abordando
antes da pausa de março.
Como vocês se lembram, até
o feriado refletimos
sobre as relações entre as pessoas
no que diz respeito à
responsabilidade moral.
Podemos dizer que a 1ª parte do
curso, a parte sobre prosperidade,
foi sobre os seres humanos
como indivíduos
e as formas que, interiormente,
é possível alcançar um
certo tipo de harmonia.
A 2ª parte do curso foi
sobre a moralidade,
sobre as relações
interpessoais entre os
indivíduos.
E a 3ª parte,
que inauguraremos na semana que vem,
é sobre como as estruturas
políticas podem desempenhar
um papel em cultivar certos
comportamentos por parte dos
indivíduos.
Claro, isso é uma idealização.
Os indivíduos considerados isoladamente
estão sempre em
interação com os outros.
Os indivíduos nas relações de pares
estão sempre dentro de
comunidades maiores.
Mas o segmento do curso é
passar de indivíduos
a pequenos grupos a grupos
maiores de pessoas.
E a unidade sobre punição, que
está a 2 aulas de distância,
é de certa forma uma
unidade de transição
entre a seção moral e a de
filosofia política.
Portanto, o que eu quero fazer neste
início, para que as pessoas
voltem a refletir sobre as
questões que temos refletido,
é fazer algumas
perguntas com o clicker.
Espero que vocês não tenham perdido
os seus clickers no feriado.
E, para começar, quero pedir para
vocês pensarem sobre uns casos
na vida real que têm a mesma
estrutura do problema do Trolley.
E depois vamos ver alguns casos
mais diretamente
relacionados com a
punição.
Vocês se lembram que dedicamos uma
atenção considerável da aula
para pensar sobre uma situação de
dilema moral abstrata e idealizada,
que às vezes é chamado de
caso da testemunha.
Há um trem que está prestes
a atingir 5 pessoas.
Há uma testemunha por
perto, que percebe
que há uma via alternativa, onde
está somente 1 pessoa.
E essa testemunha enfrenta a
escolha de desviar a ameaça,
o trem, da via onde estão 5
para a via onde está 1.
Tragicamente,
o mundo viu algo parecido num caso real,
na forma da efusão de
nuvens radioativas
de uma usina nuclear japonesa.
Portanto, esta é a 1ª pergunta:
vamos supor que você seja o
primeiro-ministro japonês
e há evidências de que a nuvem
radioativa se dirige a Tóquio,
com uma população de
cerca de 13 milhões,
e existe a possibilidade de
desviá-la para o campo,
para uma área com uma
população de cerca de 1
milhão.
A questão é:
seria 1) moralmente exigido
redirecionar a nuvem de 13
milhões para 1 milhão;
2) moralmente permitido,
mas não moralmente exigido;
ou 3) moralmente proibido?
E vamos ver os números que
saem. Último segundo...
E vamos ver. Assim que 31%
de vocês acham
que seria moralmente
exigido redirecioná-la,
56% acham que seria moralmente permitido
e 13% acham que seria
moralmente proibido.
Agora, deixa eu mostrar como vocês
responderam a essa questão
quando ela foi
apresentada
abstratamente,
como um problema do trem.
Mais do dobro,
olhando para esses números – 31%
em oposição a 15% –,
acha que é moralmente exigido
redirecionar a nuvem no caso real.
Interessante... É
interessante
metodologicamente,
porque é interessante ver
por que um caso real
oferece um tipo diferente de
resposta de um caso hipotético.
Mas também é interessante
metodologicamente notar que,
na proibição, os números foram
praticamente idênticos.
15% de vocês acharam que era
proibido no caso imaginário.
15% de vocês, na verdade, 13%,
acharam que era proibido no caso real.
Portanto, num ponto parece que
esses casos imaginários,
na sua abstração, seguem o mesmo
tipo de considerações
que os casos reais, e em
outros pontos que não.
E eu encorajo a todos, no
contexto das seções
e conversas entre vocês, a
pensarem o porquê disso.
Mas além de ser um
problema direto do trem,
o caso tradicional da testemunha,
no caso da tragédia nuclear no
Japão também existe algo
não muito diferente que podemos
chamar de "caminho do dano".
Vocês se lembram que o 2º
tipo de caso que pensamos
no contexto do Trolley era sobre um
trem que vai em direção
a 5 indivíduos e, descansando na
via, está 1 pessoa que,
se você colocá-la no caminho do dano,
poderia evitar a morte de outras 5.
Como seria a situação real
do que enfrentamos agora?
Mesmo acidente nuclear, mesmo
primeiro-ministro,
mesmas 13 milhões de pessoas, mas
agora, como primeiro-ministro,
você enfrenta a possibilidade de
enviar para a morte certa
um pequeno grupo de engenheiros,
cujo trabalho na usina é
recuperar a energia elétrica
ou baldear água em lugares
inacessíveis devido à radioatividade
para que ninguém se contamine.
Os indivíduos que estão em posição
de salvar as vidas de 13 milhões,
o sacrifício de um pequeno número.
Portanto, a questão é: para o
primeiro-ministro...
supondo que o trabalho envolva
recrutar trabalhadores...
a usina está a ponto de explodir e
gerar uma grande quantidade
de radiação a milhões de pessoas...
seria moralmente exigido,
moralmente permitido,
mas não moralmente exigido,
ou moralmente proibido
recrutar trabalhadores,
enviando-os para a morte certa?
Os números aqui são realmente
muito interessantes,
quando eu mostrá-los a vocês em
comparação com o caso abstrato.
Assim, os números são: 27%
dizem que é proibido,
41% que é permitido, mas não é
proibido, ao passo que apenas...
desculpe, 41% dizem que é
permitido, mas não exigido,
e apenas 32% acham que seria
moralmente proibido
recrutar trabalhadores para
uma morte certa.
Quais são os números de vocês
no caso do homem gordo?
Eles pareciam muito diferentes.
Então, só para mostrar a vocês,
estes foram os seus
números no caso real.
Cerca de 32% acharam que era proibido,
mais que o dobro de vocês
achou que era proibido
no caso do homem gordo.
Será que isso se dá porque,
como sugere Josh Greene,
quando uma situação é próxima e
pessoal, o jeito que você imagina
o exercício da ação de alguma
forma desempenha uma função,
seja como uma heurística moral
legítima ou ilegítima,
ao passo que quando você imagina
recrutar os trabalhadores,
o que você está fazendo é de,
certa forma, mais distante,
nos termos do caminho dano?
Será que, no caso dos trabalhadores,
isso é sentido mais como um
dano estatístico?
E, segundo Cass Sunstein, os
danos estatísticos são,
de certa forma, mais difíceis
para nós processarmos?
Será que é o que acontece
na resposta diferente
para o caso do primeiro-ministro,
cujos números de 13 milhões
comparados com um pequeno
número alteram o cálculo?
Mas se eles alteram o cálculo,
então o que conduzia a resposta
de vocês no homem gordo
não podia ter sido um
direito inviolável.
Portanto, para aqueles que
mudaram a sua posição...
observem que o exigido subiu,
o proibido desceu e o permitido subiu...
eu quero que vocês pensem sobre que
tipo de raciocínio moral
explica a diferença na resposta
de vocês para o caso real
do primeiro-ministro e o
imaginário do homem gordo.
E, como sempre, estes slides
estarão disponíveis mais tarde,
para vocês poderem analisar
atentamente os números.
Os casos que estamos
considerando até agora,
em que os terremotos provocam
desastres naturais
que causam grandes danos para as
pessoas, são tragédias.
Mas eles são tragédias no
tocante à dificuldade de saber
para onde direcionar a nossa
insatisfação com o estado do mundo.
Há muito pouco que podemos fazer
para evitar que coisas como
terremotos aconteçam.
E embora haja precauções que podemos
tomar em relação a coisas
como usinas nucleares, há
características do mundo
nas quais é difícil, para
nós, exercer controle.
O que abordamos nas aulas
antes da pausa,
no contexto da sorte moral,
foram casos em que a atitude errada
não foi perpetuada por uma
agência impessoal,
como um terremoto, mas sim
por um indivíduo.
E, assim, nós
consideramos, por
exemplo,
os 4 casos do motorista a
caminho de casa.
O Alberto Sortudo, que
chegou bem em casa;
o Alberto Azarado, que
infelizmente atropelou uma
criança;
o Celular Sortudo, que
dirigiu fazendo algo
que nenhum de vocês faz,
eu tenho certeza:
falar ao celular;
e o Celular Azarado, que foi para
casa falando ao celular
e atingiu uma criança.
Então, eu vou mostrar 2 dos
números de vocês de antes
e fazer mais uma pergunta com o clicker.
Quase todos, 95%, acharam
que o Alberto Sortudo
não fez nada moralmente
condenável ao dirigir para casa.
Lembrem-se, não estávamos falando
sobre como o seu rastro de carbono
poderia estar contribuindo para
vários tipos de problemas globais.
A única questão era saber se ele
fez algo moralmente errado
ao dirigir para casa... e 95% de
vocês disseram que não.
Por outro lado, 92%, quase
todos na classe,
pensaram que o Celular Azarado,
que estava falando ao telefone
e atingiu a criança,
fez algo moralmente condenável.
A pergunta que eu quero fazer agora,
com o auxílio dos clickers,
é se o Celular Azarado,
a pessoa que estava falando ao
telefone e atingiu a criança,
fez algo que merece punição.
E com isso vamos passar
para o tema central
da nossa discussão de hoje e quinta.
Portanto, se o Celular Azarado faz
algo que merece punição
ao dirigir falando ao telefone e,
infelizmente, atingir a criança?
Vamos ver como saem estes
números. 94% de vocês...
Nossa, mais gente acha
que ele merece punição do que
que ele fez algo errado.
Que turma!
[risos]
O que eu quero fazer nas próximas 2
aulas é refletir seriamente
sobre esse fenômeno filosófico e
psicológico bastante perturbador.
O fato de que quando
alguém faz algo errado,
e percebemos a pessoa ou o
autor da infração
como tendo tido um
determinado tipo de agência,
existe, em todas as culturas e
através dos tempos,
uma tendência a pensar que esse
indivíduo é merecedor de castigo.
Assim sendo, eu quero fazer 3
perguntas na aula de hoje.
Quero começar oferecendo a vocês
uma caracterização clássica
de punição civil,
para termos uma noção do que
é que estamos falando
e, depois, eu vou apresentá-los
a um resumo de Pojman
referente à leitura que
tínhamos para hoje,
uma obra em teoria jurídica
analítica de meados dos anos 1950.
E então vou indagar o que
é queremos dizer
quando falamos de punição
civil ou criminal.
Eu quero destacar a questão
filosófica central sobre a punição,
que é: que tipo de
justificação não tem
punição?
Vocês vão descobrir, como
observado nas leituras,
que 2 justificações
dominantes oferecidas
para a punição na verdade ecoam
2 justificações dominantes para
o constrangimento moral.
Ou seja, a grosso modo,
é possível oferecer um modelo
utilitarista de punição
e é possível oferecer um modelo
deontológico de punição.
E eu quero adentrar a mentalidade
de cada uma dessas 2
concepções de punição,
seja para ajudá-los a
refletir sobre punição,
refletir, de forma mais clara,
sobre algumas das questões
da filosofia moral
que falávamos antes da pausa.
E, claro, não vou apresentar
apenas os pontos de vista;
vou tentar dar um sentido de por
que se poderia pensar
que se tratam de
justificativas razoáveis
??
ou não razoáveis ??para a punição.
Na próxima aula, vamos analisar
a interessante literatura
psicológica, que faz
– no que diz respeito às teorias
deontológicas e utilitaristas
de punição que estamos analisando
de modo filosófico hoje –
o que parte da literatura
moral empírica
fez em relação à deontologia e
ao utilitarismo em geral.
Isto é, ela sugere o
substrato psicológico
para as nossas reações e,
em alguns casos,
tenta argumentar que isso torna
essas reações ilegítimas.
Ou ilegítimas como base para um
certo tipo de juízo normativo.
Então, outra vez, eu
quero pensar em ambas
como questionamentos sobre a
punição e como formas de refletir
sobre a crítica psicológica prática
da teoria moral mais geral,
que falamos na semana passada.
E, finalmente, o que eu quero fazer
na próxima aula é pensar
na relação entre a
punição no âmbito civil
e a punição num contexto
muito mais pessoal.
Vocês devem ter notado que
uma das leituras
para quinta-feira
é outro capítulo do que considero
o guia de parentalidade da inspiração
aristotélica de Alan Kazdin.
Portanto, deixa eu fazer uma ressalva:
o tópico punição é enorme.
Nós poderíamos oferecer um
curso inteiro só sobre ele.
E o que eu estou apresentando a
vocês na aula é uma imagem
anglo-americana "pão com manteiga"
do que a punição abrange.
Qualquer um de vocês que
refletir sobre a punição
no contexto da teoria social
encontra algumas críticas
sofisticadas para a punição
que acompanha a tradição
filosófica ocidental do século 20,
em grande parte escritas por
Nietzsche e Foucault.
E devido às limitações de tempo –
não porque isso é desinteressante,
na verdade isso é
extraordinariamente interessante
–,
não vamos abordar esses
escritores nesta classe.
Mas eu estou disponível
para falar sobre isso
durante ou fora do horário
de expediente...
Portanto, vamos começar
com a 1ª questão.
O que queremos dizer com
punição civil?
Quando vocês pressionaram o clicker
e disseram que o Celular Azarado,
o homem que fala ao telefone e
acidentalmente mata a criança,
quando vocês disseram que o Celular
Azarado merecia punição,
provavelmente vocês
estavam pensando em algo
com basicamente as 5
características consideradas
as características de casos
paradigmáticos de punição e,
talvez, até mesmo as
condições necessárias
e suficientes para que
algo seja punição.
Então a 1ª coisa, a 1ª
característica,
talvez a mais notável quando
se pensa em punição,
é que a punição é algo que envolve
um certo tipo de
desconforto ou sofrimento.
Na cultura tradicional,
a punição envolvia tanto a
imposição de algum tipo de dor
física
quanto a imposição de algum
tipo de isolamento social
e/ou de humilhação pública.
Tudo isso envolvia
desconforto e sofrimento.
Na incrível descrição dos 3 cavalos
no Fedro de Platão, que lemos no
início do semestre, o cocheiro,
no seu esforço de direcionar o
cavalo selvagem recalcitrante,
puxa as rédeas e tal forma que traz
sangue à boca do cavalo,
num intuito de castigá-lo.
Assim, a noção central
é que a punição
envolve desconforto e sofrimento.
Trata-se de transportar alguém a um
estado que causa desutilidade.
Quanto ao "cálculo felicífico",
o cálculo do bem-estar,
a relação da quantidade de
felicidade no mundo,
a punição reduz a
quantidade de bem-estar
existente nesse indivíduo.
2ª característica.
A punição não é apenas a imposição
de dor ou sofrimento a um indivíduo.
É a imposição de dor ou
sofrimento a um indivíduo
em resposta a um delito particular.
Ou a um delito legal, no caso
da punição legal.
Ou se você acha que a punição
também pode ser executada em
relação a delitos morais,
em resposta a um delito moral.
Portanto, não é sobre trazer dor
aleatoriamente ao mundo.
É trazer dor ao mundo
em resposta a um delito legal,
para a pessoa que cometeu o delito.
Portanto, não é que se algo
ruim acontece num lugar...
você descobre a pessoa e
apresenta o sofrimento a ela.
O indivíduo a quem o
sofrimento é apresentado
deve ser julgado por
quaisquer procedimentos
considerados os procedimentos legítimos
para tais julgamentos ao ter
sido um infrator.
Além disso, a punição tem
de ser administrada
intencionalmente por um agente humano.
Não é suficiente se as
forças naturais,
de alguma forma, trazem as
consequências ruins.
E vamos falar sobre isso daqui a pouco,
acerca de um quebra-cabeça, no caso
da punição retributiva.
E, finalmente, ela é imposta e
administrada não por um indivíduo
que age por si próprio ou por
uma legião de pessoas
que faz justiça pelas próprias mãos,
mas sim por uma autoridade legal
que tem a sanção do Estado
ou instituição civil por trás dela.
Portanto, a questão
levantada pela punição
– e vamos refletir
sobre isso novamente
quando começarmos a falar sobre a
teoria política mais geral –
é como um Estado poderia
ser justificado
ao causar dano a um dos seus membros.
Como poderia ser legítimo
para uma sociedade
fazer com que um de seus indivíduos
sofra ou sinta desconforto?
Portanto, há 2 tipos básicos de
justificação oferecidos para a punição.
A 1ª é uma justificação prospectiva.
É aquela que diz que a punição
é um mecanismo eficaz
para evitar danos futuros.
Quando alguém age de uma forma
que viola as normas legais
ou sociais; quando o
indivíduo sugere, talvez,
a possibilidade de agir
novamente dessa forma.
E, então, é importante desativá-la.
Ou quando um indivíduo age de uma forma
que viola as normas legais ou sociais e
outros veem que o indivíduo
agiu dessa forma e não recebeu
nenhuma consequência negativa
da comunidade; como resultado,
outros estarão propensos a
agir dessa forma.
E assim, a punição tem a
função de dissuasão pública.
Independentemente da forma como
é operacionalizada,
e vamos falar um pouco mais sobre
isso no final da aula,
a motivação básica para a
justificação prospectiva da punição
é que a punição é um meio
eficaz de evitar danos futuros.
De modo que, de alguma forma, o
sofrimento do indivíduo
punido em nome do Estado
é compensado pelos benefícios
a outros indivíduos,
como consequência
de tê-los causado sofrimento.
É um trade-off de
desutilidade e utilidade.
O 2º tipo de justificação
para a punição...
e deixa eu dizer que aqueles que
se sentiram insatisfeitos
com o número 1, mas frustrados por Kant
na nossa discussão sobre teoria
moral de antes da pausa,
têm algo para refletir sobre como as
visões de mundo se encaixam.
A 2ª justificação para a punição é
que a punição é invocada porque,
quando alguém viola
códigos morais ou legais,
esse alguém merece ser punido.
A justificação não é que é uma
forma de evitar danos futuros,
embora isso possa ocorrer
para causar um benefício agregado.
A razão pela qual um indivíduo
deve ser punido nesta imagem
é porque, ao cometer uma
violação moral ou legal,
a pessoa violou o código moral ou legal
de tal forma que o que ela
merece é ser punida.
Portanto, essas são as 2
justificativas que vamos analisar.
Mas quero salientar que há outra maneira
de refletir sobre a punição,
que vamos comentar um pouco
mais no contexto da aula:
que vocês podem pensar
sobre a punição
como uma resposta a uma
ruptura da ordem social,
de tal forma que, pelo menos, 2
pessoas estão envolvidas.
Uma delas, a vítima,
à qual, se você deseja
restaurar o estado pré-dano,
o importante para pensar no
contexto da punição não é nem
a grande questão sobre a
retribuição nem sobre a dissuasão
– embora elas sejam
importantes para o indivíduo
como um membro da sociedade –,
mas sim, no caso deste
crime específico,
a reflexão é sobre a restituição.
O que pode ser feito
para restaurar o indivíduo ao
seu estado pré-dano?
E, no caso do infrator, refletir
sobre o que pode ser feito
para restaurar esse indivíduo
ao que se poderia pensar
como um estado pré-dano maior e
mais global, ou seja,
para uma situação de
pró-sociabilidade.
Bom, vamos ilustrar essas 4 ideias
com um exemplo particular.
Aqui está o nosso velho amigo Giges...
Lembram-se dele?
Lá estava ele e, por
enquanto, ele tem um cavalo.
Giges tem um cavalo e
então aparece Pedro,
o nosso vilão de "Jim e os índios";
e Pedro vai e rouba o cavalo de Giges.
Agora, o que deve ser feito?
Bem, se a questão que nos interessa
é a recuperação da
situação do estado pré-dano,
então a nossa principal
preocupação é com a
restituição.
Queremos que Pedro devolva
o cavalo a Giges.
Vamos supor que, em vez de
roubar o cavalo de Giges,
Pedro tivesse matado o animal.
Poderíamos pensar, então, que o que
exige a restituição é apresentar
a Giges algo tão bom como o
cavalo que ele tinha antes.
Talvez Pedro tenha de dar um de
seus cavalos a Giges.
Mas a imagem que
fundamenta a restituição
– e vamos falar dos aspectos
problemáticos da restituição –
ao restaurar o estado de pré-dano
envolve algo um pouco mais complicado
do que dar de volta a propriedade
roubada ou substituir em espécie.
A noção por trás da restituição
é a de que o objetivo em que o
Estado tem razão legítima
para se envolver é ao considerar a
parte inocente e certificar-se
que ela não esteja pior depois que
antes de ter sofrido um crime.
O que a noção de reabilitação nos
diz para fazer nessa condição?
Bem, provavelmente ela nos
diz para pensar em...
aí está Pedro com um cajado...
como podemos ajudar alguém cujas
interações com a sociedade
envolvem as violações de suas normas,
de modo que ele interiorize essas normas
e elas se tornem a fundamentação
para o seu comportamento?
De certa maneira, a
reabilitação é o meio mais
eficaz
de dissuasão e prevenção.
Se é possível restabelecer
a pró-sociabilidade
em indivíduos a quem expressamos
preocupação por meio da punição,
isso não seria o meio mais eficaz?
Portanto, esta é uma versão
que merece reflexão.
Podemos pensar na
restituição para quem
sofre
e na reabilitação para
quem causa o dano.
De modo alternativo, podemos
pensar na questão
a partir das 2 categorias que vamos
focar no restante da aula.
Ou seja, podemos trancar o Pedro
numa cela e justificar
que isso vai impedir que ele
cometa outro crime no futuro.
Ou podemos trancar o Pedro numa
cela com o pensamento...
vejam o slide, é a única
piada em toda a aula...
de que, ao fazer isso,
manifestamos a justiça.
E, na verdade, há outra
piada visual mais tarde
sobre como isso faz parte da
nossa cultura pop,
dos desenhos animados, dos
quadrinhos, dos filmes...
de alguma forma, a apresentação da
justiça perante um infrator
é absolutamente crucial para o
bem-estar da sociedade.
Então o que eu quero fazer agora
é introduzir a vocês
esses 2 tipos de justificações, desde
dentro, desde a obra de Kant
e depois de forma mais geral;
e, em seguida, analisar o
trabalho de Rawls.
Bom, vamos começar com as
perspectivas retribucionistas.
A grosso modo, essa é a
perspectiva de que quando alguém
faz algo que viola as normas
legais ou morais,
ele comete um erro e,
ao fazer isso, desalinha a balança
da justiça de alguma forma.
E que a punição faz é
reorientar a balança da justiça,
reequilibrar as coisas.
Punindo o causador do dano,
nós reorientamos o mundo
de tal maneira que a
injustiça é reponderada,
esse "deserto" é servido o infrator.
O texto que lemos discutindo as
perspectivas retribucionistas
é de Immanuel Kant.
E Kant explicita:
"a punição jurídica não
pode ser administrada
apenas como um meio para
promover uma outra boa,
tanto no que diz respeito ao infrator
quanto à sociedade civil".
Ou seja, dissuasão, prevenção de
danos futuros, reabilitação...
todas essas – as outras
coisas boas –
podem estar na esteira da punição.
Mas não podem ser a
justificativa para a ação.
"A punição jurídica – diz Kant
– só pode ser imposta
porque a pessoa sobre quem ela é
infligida cometeu um crime".
Isto é uma parte da visão
mais geral de Kant.
Vocês se lembram das páginas
iniciais do Fundamentação,
que Kant não está interessado em
pensar nas consequências.
Kant está interessado em
pensar na retidão moral
e na forma que os nossos comportamentos
e instituições sociais refletem
o nosso reconhecimento
desse fato fundamental sobre o mundo.
Portanto, aqueles que são
atraídos pela imagem
de que os infratores merecem
os seus desertos,
não por razões utilitárias,
mas pelas fundamentais,
precisam saber se isso traz na
esteira um compromisso
com algo parecido com a
perspectiva kantiana mais geral,
de que a boa vontade é boa não
pelo que ela afeta ou realiza,
mas por ser boa em si mesma.
Esse é o cerne da
perspectiva retribucionista.
A perspectiva retribucionista
muitas vezes traz com ela...
além de uma resposta para a pergunta,
qual é a justificação
para a punição?
Resposta: deserto moral...
um modelo que Kant, na
leitura para hoje,
chama de princípio e norma
da justiça pública.
Ou seja, o retributivismo
inclui não apenas a ideia
de que os infratores merecem punição,
mas também uma imagem dos
motivos dessa punição
e, às vezes, uma caracterização
do que abrangem essas
sanções específicas.
Kant escreve: "o mal indevido que
alguém comete ao outro
é para ser considerado como algo
perpetrado a si mesmo".
Ou seja, uma justificação
baseada nos princípios
para a punição relativo ao
dano cometido por alguém
está na base da imagem de Kant.
Ele continua: "quem rouba faz de
toda propriedade insegura.
Ele, portanto, rouba a si mesmo de
segurança na propriedade,
em consonância com o
direito de retaliação".
A punição para o roubo é a perda
da propriedade, diz Kant,
no princípio de que o mal indevido
que alguém comete ao outro
deve ser considerado como
cometido a si mesmo.
A lógica desse argumento
traz consigo a conclusão
destacada por Pojman em Kant:
"quem comete assassinato deve morrer".
Eu não tenho certeza se o grifos
são do original em alemão,
mas eles não servem para
tornar o texto mais eficaz
para quem está voltando do feriado
e procura um auxílio na leitura...
Portanto, a imagem que a
retaliação que é exigida
pelo deserto moral, que a
retribuição pelos danos
traz com ela a exigência da
perpetração de um dano semelhante,
tem um formato particular na
articulação kantiana.
A ideia de que a morte deve ser
servida a alguém que comete
um crime de morte atinge a
muitos como uma forma,
não de expressar
retribuição, mas de
vingança.
E eu quero apresentar uma
análise excelente,
que foi observada numa das
leituras, de Robert Nozick,
a quem iremos conferir mais
argumentos prévios e posteriores.
Uma ótima análise oferecida
por ele da diferença
entre retribuição e vingança.
Porque eu quero tentar dar
uma imagem muito clara
da abrangência da imagem
retribucionista.
Assim, um eixo em que vocês podem
contrastar retaliação e vingança
é aquele que desencadeia um
desejo de vingança.
E Nozick diz que a
retribuição é desencadeada
por um erro legal ou moral, uma
violação de um código
que é aceito por todas as partes,
embora possa ter sido
violada por uma delas,
enquanto a vingança pode
ocorrer em resposta a um dano
ou uma desfeita, não por uma
violação do código moral como tal.
Há limites para a
retribuição, diz Nozick.
Kant articulou apenas uma versão.
Punimos exatamente na
proporção do dano causado,
na imagem de Kant.
Por outro lado, a vingança é,
em princípio, ilimitado.
Em termos de personalidade envolvida,
no grau de personalização,
a retribuição é impessoal, é
levada a cabo pelo Estado.
Lembrem-se: isso foi uma das
nossas caracterizações,
um dos elementos da nossa
caracterização de punição.
Ao passo que a vingança é pessoal.
É levada a cabo por um indivíduo
por uma questão de expressar a
insatisfação individual.
A retribuição difere da
vingança em tom emocional.
Quando a pessoa se engaja
na retribuição,
ou ela tem prazer na
justiça em si mesma
ou não tem nenhum sentimento emocional.
Quando você coloca um
infrator na cadeia,
o prazer é ter feito a coisa certa, na
medida exigida pela justiça,
e não o prazer em ver o
sofrimento alheio.
Há um tipo de generalidade
anexada à retribuição.
Um indivíduo que executa
um ato particular
num determinado tipo de
circunstância, seja ele quem for,
será digno de retribuição.
Ao passo que, no caso da vingança,
trata-se de uma pessoa específica
num momento específico,
e não uma postura de uma categoria,
mas um malfeitor em particular nos
olhos de quem se vinga.
Há uma semelhança entre
retribuição e vingança,
e é que ambas são atos expressivos.
Em ambos os casos,
o alvo deve saber por que a pena
está sendo infligida;
e para saber isso ele se
destina a saber disso.
Novamente, estes slides
estarão na rede,
se vocês não captarem
todos os detalhes.
Mas o quadro de
retribuição que nos
interessa
é o da esquerda.
Então, eu quero comentar sobre 2
casos em que essa condição
dá origem a situações potencialmente
divertidas ou desconcertantes.
Um deles, um caso de vingança; o
outro, um caso de retribuição.
Portanto, como se sabe, um
tropo nos quadrinhos
é que o vilão está sempre tentando
matar o herói de tal forma
que o herói sabe por que o vilão
está tentando fazer isso.
E os que estão familiarizados
com o Austin Powers
sabem que o Austin Powers é sempre
capaz de escapar do Dr.Evil
porque o Dr. Evil está tão preocupado
com o que podemos pensar sobre a
restrição da notoriedade
ou o papel expressivo da vingança...
Mas, além de criar linhas de
enredo em filmes de paródia,
o fenômeno cuja a retribuição envolve
um tipo particular de
causar dano dá origem
a um fenômeno desconcertante,
que poderíamos chamar de justiça
enquanto o mundo acaba.
Nozick escreve: "as condições que
demarcam a retribuição
explicam o que, de outra forma,
parece ser um fenômeno absurdo.
Se alguém condenado à morte
fica seriamente doente
ou tenta o suicídio, a
execução é adiada
e são tomadas medidas para
restabelecer a saúde da pessoa
condenada, para que ela, em
seguida, possa ser executada.
Isso porque a punição dela envolve
algo que está sendo apresentado
acima dela, por outros,
como resultado da maldade do seu ato.
A sua morte por causas naturais
ou pelas suas próprias
mãos evita isso,
então são tomadas as medidas
para restaurar a punição."
Observe como isso vai lado a lado
com a discussão do caso do
afogamento infantil
no Utilitarismo de Mill, por um lado,
e na Fundamentação de Kant, por outro.
Mill só está interessado em
tirar a criança do lago
e não em saber se você faz isso
porque você está se exibindo
para alguém que você
quer impressionar,
tentando receber uma
recompensa financeira
ou expressando um certo tipo
de compromisso moral.
Kant está interessado em por que
você está fazendo isso.
Aqui também.
A imagem retribucionista diz
que o que importa
não é a morte do infrator, no fim das
contas, de qualquer maneira.
O que importa é a morte
ou punição do infrator da maneira
certa, no fim das contas,
em função de um processo particular.
Então, vamos concluir a aula de hoje
e continuar com o
utilitarismo na próxima
aula
citando o perturbador final de Kant,
já que agora vocês estão em
condições de compreender.
Kant escreve... se é 2012 e o
mundo está acabando,
como ocorre no filme, e as ondas
estão vindo e os raios caindo,
e a nova Idade do Gelo
está emergindo...
a 1ª coisa que você precisa fazer
antes de o mundo acabar,
diz Kant, é executar todo mundo
no corredor da morte.
"Mesmo se a sociedade civil
resolvesse dissolver-se,
o último assassino deitado na
prisão – afirmo Kant –
deve ser executado antes do
fim. Isso deve ser feito
– esta é a imagem retribucionista –
para que todos possam perceber o
deserto de seus atos."
Então, voltamos na quinta com a
justificação utilitária para a
punição.
Até lá.